Alvarez
and at this moment Nicolás Maduro is making statements
and has referred to the presidential elections in Venezuela.
See what he just said just minutes ago.
Venezuela is not tainted by you or anyone Presidential elections
touch constitutional mandate It will be fulfilled again in
Venezuela in an manner when they touch when the electoral power convenes
withtion withouttion with sanctions without sanctions If they
do not put them Venezuela will go to presidential elections and
the Venezuelan people will have a new great victory this year 2.
024 to clear the way to 2.
030 and beyond Be assured of that
Oh God given Jorge what happened With sanctions or without sanctions
Nicolás Maduro has just said that there will be elections in this
2,024 and your speech that until you raise the total sanctions here
there will be no presidential elections In Venezuela you realize
that there is a measurement of forces there Pausa we already come with more.